welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
really excited to finally be joined by
James Blackwell who is the CEO of a
recruitment business called Ronald James
group and they are the leading digital
and tech and recruitment business that
are based in the Northeast and they have
13 staff currently and he's built this
business into a seven-figure business in
four years and James are a young
recruitment entrepreneur I'm excited to
have you on here we've been speaking a
little while and good to finally having
you on how are you I'm very well he
shouldn't thanks very much for inviting
me on and I'll be honest how many
recruitment business owners or
recruiters have I had on that from your
part of the world I actually think he
might be the first typically before
obviously all this went on I would
definitely prefer doing them face to
face so I would find myself quite often
in Manchester or Birmingham Bristol but
never quite made up to Newcastle so I'm
excited you've saved a journey anyway
yeah exactly so look as I said James
where I always love to start on this
podcast is how did James black go on to
the the lovely world of recruitment how
did that happen yeah I suppose
same one-liners everyone else fell into
recruitment yeah I had my own coffee
shop when I was 21 had that for two
years and built up quite successfully
until the initial recession came in 2008
and I got out of that and then I got
offered a job at BMW to sell cars and I
really learned my trade from there for
five years selling BMWs and minis and
then I just got an opportunity through
my sister that times ex-boyfriend was
working in recruitment and I didn't
realize how much money could be made in
recruitment and I realized that it was a
sales job where in recoupment it is
ultimate sales job so yeah started on a
company called Nigel front front group
and I literally took a big leap because
I was 27 28
okay money as a car salesman and I had
to take a drop back down I think at the
time was like 15 K basic salary because
the basically salary isn't typically
good as a car salesperson though isn't
it but you can I'm assuming you can
build a heart yes it was bad as a car
sell them but you were always going to
do 15 to 20 cars a month yeah especially
when you've been there for a while you
you know and expect what you're gonna be
doing them on a monthly basis so it was
leaping in your head met quite you know
that typical conversation of you got to
take a step back so tech step forward
and all of that so use 2728 at the time
just just quickly then so just to frame
up for everyone and give it a run
context so then you then worked another
frank there's like five years wasn't
that I saw um yeah LinkedIn and then
after that you then obviously you set up
and started running old James which been
going for four and a bit years now just
quickly how and why did you did you open
the coffee shop like I have to ask that
okay yeah let's just start there quick
cuz I think that's going to be
interested in the fact that you had that
experience early on which I'm sure gave
you some lessons they have helped with
ronald james of course it did yes i mean
i was always entrepreneurial as a kid
selling sweets pop snacks and stuff same
stories most entrepreneurs i suppose and
then I got into car auctions and I
bought my first car when I was 17 my
passed my test
I bought if I like 350 pounds and I put
it on the drive for a 795 and sold it
within a day I got the bug of buying and
selling so I started buying and selling
cars and I built up the good amount of
money I think is about 10 15 K yeah
that's opportunity to help a coffee shop
and take it over that's how I got into
where where did where did whether this
entrepreneurial mindset life like where
did that come from because that that's
not a typical I know I see you'd hear
that a lot from entrepreneurs are
selling stuff la blah blah and I know I
had a bit of that but I did I definitely
didn't have his like didn't go through
do things like that that you said but
like where did that come from what
environment we brought him good point
nothing general or middle class
environment but my dad was like a
salesperson you always wore a suit a
suitcase and used to take me to work
sometimes and
in the car option sometimes as well and
it was funny because I had an
opportunity I played like semi-pro level
as a footballer so I was always
competitive you know my passion was like
even when I was young I wanted to be a
businessman like I was acting up in a
suit and I love business so I think
that's where it's time from like my dad
growing up and being surrounded by
business like I was always had a passion
to buy and sell as well well your
friends like yeah like that age cuz like
do you know I mean sometimes I remember
back in mice and like fingers and the
people and my growing up like you can
sometimes alienate yourself when you
become not really focused on like work
or business or buying and selling stuff
rather than the typical
thing so I guess it was only influence
in your friends like did you have an
interest in friendship group yeah it's a
good point I think I've transitioned as
most people do when they grow up you
have different theories of friends I
would say yeah and is the famous Jim
Rohn always says you are the average of
the five people you hung around with
so I wouldn't say back then I was ultra
focused and I think that's what was one
of the biggest learning curves for me
especially with the coffee shop was I
wasn't into personal growth at the time
yeah personal development and I'd
surrounded myself probably with the
wrong people I was still young partying
doing it everyone else does good it
would be fair whatever like everyone
else does back then you were a bit
stupid and crazy so now I learned from
that mistake in terms of be careful who
you surround yourself with so as I've
growing I've quite different friend and
peer groups now so a lot of the friends
I've got know I've got maybe two or
three core friends and then the rest of
people I've even met through business
who are either millionaires I've met
some billionaires and I've surrounded
myself with different people with
different mindsets okay I my standards
are always high yeah I think that's not
just business successful are they
successful personally have they got
philosophy wisdom about them other got
good morals all those type of things
I'm always evaluating ok cool I'll just
curious ik is yeah I think late teens
early 2000 buying and selling cars
it's just interesting right absolutely
love that so I guess what was your
perception of recruitment when you got
in recruitment then sort of like did you
have any perception of it at all or she
didn't recognize it as a luck acquiring
quite proper sales job what what was
your perception of recruitment yeah it
was quite hard at first to get your head
around it so it's got a click at some
point like one day I used to hire
recruiters as I started being a team
leader manager like it's got a click in
the first few weeks if it doesn't it's
probably not that was not going to drop
but is it it did take a while to
understand if you're trying to create
something from nothing and you're trying
to deal with people's emotions to try
and create an opportunity for them and
trying to create the opportunity with
the client as well it took a few weeks
but then once it clicks like you do
really get it yeah but it's it is simple
as obviously you get it kind of inclined
to match them together but in reality
when you're actually doing it you need
to understand at first and speak to the
market and understand following the
scripts was a big thing for me as well
like that give you a pivot and a an
anchor to actually follow just a process
and then things start tripping in and
falling into place
I understand why I ask those questions
now I understand it's not just about
getting the candidate and putting them
into a company you have to understand
the why and the reason behind it and
this there's a lot of complexities to
when you peel it back of like how you
actually make a placement okay so yeah
okay and so I definitely want to really
focus on sort of James the recruitment
business owner but obviously let's just
think about your your time at Nigel
Frank was you a permanent contract
recruiter or what was the what top did
you recruit pan permanent positions or
was it by four yeah and I was all
permanence
so what market did you agree on at that
time did like IT like Microsoft type of
recruitment which is what my top rank
was renowned for so it was really neat
sector specific where you got a
territory in a region and you couldn't
really go outside of that location and
then you've got a bundle of candidates
in CRM that was
when LinkedIn was just sort of coming
into player but it was pretty much like
80% replacements were made off CRM
systems
no recent job adverts actually remember
I stuff to come in at 7:00 a.m. I was
fighting with everyone else to get on
the job boards none of it beforehand
this was maybe one two decent candidates
a day that you would probably get yeah
but then it was good and I think that
was a really good learning curve because
we could has now got all of the luxury
like my team have got everything from
LinkedIn we could email finders video
recording software I've got calls for
them obviously we've got loads of retain
clients like the job now as a recruiter
is is a lot different to what it was
back then so and so you're sort of
career at Nigel Frank was the typical
joiner as a trainee or consultant and
then you became a manager leader and by
the time you left you as a manager yeah
what consumed on okay so I'll see
they're a big agency right a lot of
people to compete with why why did James
rise to wider James become a leader in
that organization I'd like to Frank it
was it was it was a good culture that I
mean that the really nailed the culture
back then so it was like a cult as it
were but you were literally like you
were just absorbed into what they do
there and I don't know I think it was
just a case I think I was like top three
Billa for EMEA like and I was just
really driven it was great wearing a
suit feeling special in that city and
yeah I suppose I could work like not
gonna lie like you were in seven I was
in seven eight o'clock and I was leaving
at 7 in my place so you put a lot of
time and effort into it for sure
and so it's it's not for the
faint-hearted back then but you did get
rewarded well like paid well the looked
after the good employees he got great
incentives so back then like at any one
age 27 28 was it was probably the best
job we could ever get in the northeast
of England for sure I mean there wasn't
many others that were earning more
what you could earn as a recruiter okay
any any other sort of in hindsight
looking back good like anything else
because look a lot of people that listen
to this podcast they're they're people
that want to be the best version
themselves want to be at the top right
so I guess one disorder in a bit here is
that particularly in the in a big brand
like nhadra Frank like there's like you
could very easily be someone in the
middle of the table right so there's a B
so yeah it's not free there so you've
already said work ethic hard work which
comes up a lot and is so in important so
I guess in hindsight before we talked
about you start on your own business and
like anything else do you think that
really contributed or enabled you to be
in that top free spot do you think that
is worth I would probably just say
mindset so I'm not when I started
getting into a bit of personal
development listening to podcasts on the
way to work
one of the first audiobooks a listen he
was thinking which yes yeah like really
why didn't because I think it was just
in case of like I was I just wanted to
be the best so and I think I had a group
off like friends with in there that were
all at a similar level so we always
buffing and we used to have little bets
on who would be the top fella for the
month of the office and I was always
like ego driven and obviously
competitive for my nature but football
like I wanted to win yeah always about
being the best who build the most I look
the pressure on my shoulders just like
people do in football I would always be
the one that wanted to step up take the
final minute penalty and all that type
of stuff you can translate into
equipment and I think that's probably
what came out was the fact that my inner
competitiveness to win and to always
keep improving I've always been like the
best version of myself like I wanted to
give everything so there's no like tip
trick or hock like it is just it is
mindset and yeah being able to because
there was hard workers like even in that
agency these hard workers and me but
you've got to be street smart I think I
was lucky that hard the the binding
salon of course
business that was different because I
was probably one of the only people back
then that they hired without a degree so
they're very very picky and they would
go me interview ten and hire one and
literally they had no degree the chances
would be getting higher very very slim
so but then I knew I had a point to
prove and like I started our review so I
asked for against all of these people
that were sort of a legal they've had a
degree and everything else I got had a
point to prove nothing that's what
worked for me okay so what what gave you
the confidence to to start your own
recruitment business then what why why
did he yeah where did that come from and
why did you decide to do that yeah so
like I mean I was really happy back then
where I was and obviously the business
was going well I got shares in the
business that obviously was going to be
six figures and I think we're gonna get
paid on a takeover but I started to get
into personal development I started to
follow the likes of grun Cardone I
remember the other influences and that
entrepreneurial hook came back yeah it
suppressed probably when I was there a
little bit because I was just so focused
and in terms of the woman is doing doing
doing that's when I started really
reflecting and working on myself and
realizing that if I am ever gonna be
what I want to be in a multi-millionaire
like there's not many millionaires that
make a million wouldn't for somebody
else there is there's a small percentage
but and I like the freedom like I was I
got to a point there where I was five
years in I was a bit stressed I went
through like a bit of anxiety in
everything else because the the world I
created and the person I'd created
wasn't me so I changed as a person and I
probably didn't I wasn't the nice type
of person maybe it's nice as what I am
now like I changed well you're just like
the typical villain Abed yeah and I
think it's really interesting because
like when you're five years in and as
you said you've like that's the person
that you've been to get to the top and
that's been rewarded blah blah blah that
you then carry that with you and it's
it's hot like it's hard for you not to
be that right or like
to carry that pressure on yourself so
that's interesting
fair enough what was there a particular
moment then where you're like right like
let I'm gonna start my own recruitment
business or because like just quickly
the you spy drone or James on your own
yeah so like you know probably for six
months I saw what was going on my head I
had friends and we've gone on lunch and
talked around like should we leave him
but then there was no mentorship
guidance so there's no courses not
instructor on how you're actually doing
so is like a lot unknown and fear is
probably the biggest thing that holds
most people back as we know yeah so it's
finding through the fear cuz I remember
back then when we were looking into just
let me know how much would it cost is
your website and this thing was like
twenty thousand pounds but it's not like
a website of anything all you need loads
of money to stop yeah it's crazy because
like what year was that that was like
2015 it's crazy that there wasn't a lot
compared to like the amount of content
now with this podcast and all the other
things like it's crazy how much that's
come on but you're completely right that
I completely understand that like having
access to that sort of information just
simply didn't exist which is crazy isn't
it you just wouldn't think that's the
case right now yeah well now there's
tons I mean great podcast that you do a
showman there's loads aren't there I
think I offend I mean I remember when I
first started a podcast were going
Ripper yeah you think that a new
equipment that was the only thing online
that was talking about recruitment crazy
like googled I know and remember but
then you were relying on the brand and
the data this year yeah that was like a
big selling point wasn't is like we've
got a hundred thousand people with
such-and-such from our database that was
like part of the pitch yeah and so what
what ended up being the game plan then
so there wasn't many people that you
could pick their brain there wasn't
content you could access what we'll
ended up being this all game plan
because I think and as you just said
like quite rightly people taking the
leap people being paralyzed by the fear
of what that first is and like are they
going to be as successful on their own
or else out of the ecosystem that
they've been used to what what ended up
being the game plan for that first year
yes it was like
a lot of personal developments are just
trying to read I read a book a week I
was reading a lot around business
fundamentals and how they help start a
business and then how to plan what I
thought would be a plan was picking a
market that was similar to what Nigel
Franklin put in Salesforce because I
thought oh well in theory they've got a
great Salesforce team I'll just do
Salesforce recruitment but it really
doesn't work like that because you need
to have a clear way of how you would map
out the market and build out a niche
with the proper structure okay like
because like a niche vertical will have
like various different gradients within
it so yes you could like have a specific
group of high clients and candidates
within a niche that someone else is
successful with but that doesn't mean
that you can just step in there and be
really successful yourself so like the
first that was probably a mistake like
we had as the new focus on Salesforce
for probably like three four weeks and
then we just got obviously I was based
in a northeast we got talking to you and
I just Network like a hustled and just
went loads of business events Network
pulled it like pulled an IT developer
job and we worked out it worked and then
all of a sudden we just fell into like
the northeast tech market which was open
coming at the time and that's a very
similar like story to how Sean and Nigel
start at neither front like they didn't
aim to do Microsoft Dynamics they were
doing something totally different really
just fell into it I think something
that's really start stuck with me is
where you started and where you finish
hmm and I think that's so important to
realize that you might have in your head
where you want to be but just like
because right now what you're starting
and what you're doing isn't like you
know I mean which is pretty much what
you just said and I think that's so
important to remember that if you're
standing on business or did Justin just
in general and okay so a couple of weeks
then recognize that so then just quite
organically for you hustling and meeting
people and you ended up falling into or
focusing on I'm working with northeast
tech yes I think like the reason I
started the business was like I wanted
more freedom because I didn't want to
work it earlier anymore
yeah
the Deaf of five is solid like you just
get burn out like most recruiters get
burned I'm doing that yeah
enable like long-term like it's not good
for your health at all mmm yep there's
definitely better way so freedom I
wanted more money because I was
restricted you always respected tomorrow
deals you can do in and and then
lifestyle because I want it to be all I
can be
the only way and do that's Express that
is to have full control over my destiny
and then the more time I spent on myself
and I'm side of the business in a flow
state and the faster like suddenly my
business grew so I was like getting my
consortin conditions right so things
like personality profiling and testing
so I recommend ever and try like Myers
Brigg tests and myers-briggs it's like I
think 16 personalities calm okay you
understand how you work how do you think
how you operate because you want to get
there starting conditions right when you
start the business otherwise you'll end
up building a business that you truly
hate because um you want to be fulfilled
in in what you actually do it's really
important to actually understand
yourself first before you are just
certainly steamin and set up a business
now all of a sudden a lot of business
owners have got a job now that's
actually in existence they don't enjoy
business anymore and I was really really
tough on that right from the store and a
lot of people tell you that I was all
about lifestyle and the business serves
me I do not serve the business like
there that was the starting conditions
from day one yes I still put in the
hustle and the hard work to get it to
where it was but after that time once
I'm the business is making profit I'm
taking my $600
yeah and not really helped because but
but it takes time yes so like it's Skype
skyscrapers are built on individual
bricks so it's like Lin each new brick
is a single job so once you have to like
build it client acquisition system how
can we get that fulfilled so that then
it's all about talking around having
systems with any business and it was a
big systems thing it can we leverage
technology tools
marketing to make sure this business can
wouldn't without me and everything
systemized otherwise that starts get
broken as well I'm already dealing with
people which is recruiters and you can't
systemize a recruiter but everything
else in the business it's important
because you have to break it down into
bite-sized chunks and make sure the
built each pillar and each part of the
system correctly I'm keen to dive into
that because I think because I think a
lot of a lot of people that own a
business of your size or and yeah are in
those thoughts environments will think
that there's no way that I could step
away from the business right or it could
run you right so I'm interested about
that down but what I'm always keen to
sort of get your thoughts learnings and
experiences from is that first year in
in sort of James running his own
recruitment business so you said quite
early on you ended up sort of adapting
and pivoting like what how how did the
end of the first year look like what
what went on in that first year yeah it
was interesting because I still remember
to this day in the first we got two or
three weeks was really hard when I was
like I remember being in a coffee shop
and I think it was casta my girlfriend
was how old of you at that point so it's
a button 28:29 yeah I was like wow this
is tough like you starting off with no
database no structure LinkedIn it's
quite new then and hadn't I didn't have
a template or blueprint to follow in
terms of how do I actually win clients
of them all with call calling Jason
needs all of that as I thought this is
going to be hard
yeah and then I started learning and
started studying all of the greats like
from different sectors and different
environments not recruitment and then I
work down like a way of how to copy map
on the market how to have a structure
and how to build a niche within a niche
like I saw it to know like once we
started doing a couple of placements I
realized that if we can nail down on one
location in one key key market with like
two or three job titles marks I think we
could really drill down enough because I
knew that was a growing market in trend
so that's why when we really double down
by the first year started off and then
evolution could you send wheeler
me my younger brother so he what 18
something in 18 at the time he left with
no qualification from school he was just
at home and obviously started on a
kitchen table and I was like look why
don't you join me and I just literally
trained him up on the candidate side so
I gave him the script I just went out
and hustled and met as many
entrepreneurs and other business owners
as possible so I sell like email
automation campaign and a reach out
strategy to meet as many potential
clients as possible just for a chat for
20 minutes and then I just really like
hustled myself and a lot of people gave
me an opportunity and started giving me
jobs and then me my brother would work
on work on the jobs but like I said
starting conditions from a start I hate
dealing with the candidate side no
disrespect to candidates
yeah well it no I was I'm not doing that
anymore what I love doing is going out
selling pitch in winning client's
business and then handed off so I just
focused that time I'm training my
brother work to be an understanding
source of inclusive candidate so I'd
help him with the closing process so we
actually built like a good environment
where I win all of the kinds really
build that out and be the face of the
business and he was there just really he
really adapted to like LinkedIn finding
the right candidates known how to spot a
good candidate for a job and then it was
just me and him first here we did about
I think was three hundred thirty
thousand pounds per fees or in the first
year two shooters yeah so that was money
at the time like if you know Jesus in
like 60 70 kick he's doing that from
just quickly and what sort came up for
me when you're talking about that I
think like what what was the pitch or
what was the story that you said to
these North East business owners that
made them sort of give you a chance
because that's because I think a lot of
people when they're starting out evaced
on and brand new desk or starting their
own recruitment business like I think a
lot of people can find out quite
challenging contiune especially like
you've done you've ended up doing a
market that you quite haven't done
before so you recognize an opportunity
like like a lot of people may think now
I've got recruitment but I don't know
the mark
like like how they're going to react
other known like what was the what was
the story what was the pitch that the
ended up working well war that made
these businesses give you a chance yeah
it's a good point because it's like the
people I reached on to with business
owners and founders themselves so I was
reaching out as a young hungry
entrepreneur that is nearly ants now
that's not all what it takes like
success is not to be pursued it's like
it's to be attracted by the person you
want to become so what got me is a good
recruiter a nice upfront was not going
to get me to doing six seven figures you
know business owner like I had it fully
changes a person's different yeah
because I had to attract the type of
people that I wanted as clients so if I
was just going is another recruiter that
that end user client that entrepreneur
that self azam business he wouldn't be
interested so I needed to to raise my
game so that was knowledge so knowledge
is power verse or like reading books
about the billionaires and millionaires
going to masterminds events surrounding
myself with other people in network and
push myself outside the comfort zone
because then I could speak their
language and be interested in them and
actually give value back so a lot of
people like ask well how do I get a
mentor it's like you've got to give
value to them as well like do they want
to do they want to speak to you can you
provide value back so in that market it
wasn't just did I know about the tech it
was a knew a lot about business and I
could I used to give people cool hacks
on LinkedIn automation email mark in the
norm H now could always be trying to
help that customer incline as well as
say cannot kind of hold you know we did
you know how we can help yeah yeah so
that's what was probably the biggest
thing was like I'm not going on there
kind of have a job yes I asked but I
also provided volume because I think
part of that fear or that is that light
so how to communicate where you are as a
business you know I mean do I be on this
do I say that it's me and my younger
brother and my kitchen table just
hustling did you know I mean cuz I
thought that's part of it is whether you
got to do of it isn't it it's like so
I'll get you a Centon I love that but I
think that that's also part of it isn't
that of course it is and perception is
reality yeah so one of my old mentor was
done Pena
50 billion dollar man if you look them
up on YouTube
he says practice practice success before
he's successful so good are the world's
widest coverage yeah leather sit in the
car like I did a YouTube video on my
youtube channel James blackwell let me
check it out where I was having the
Ferrari for a couple of days there which
I swap for my Porsche with a friend and
it was like you just want to surround
yourself with these things so you can
attract them more and but it's also
perception is reality Sonja my business
I would never go to a client and say
it's just me I would say I've got I've
got a team now that team is one under
couple of beers but that team could be
perception of being 15 20 so you're when
you start up like I always try to
perceive ourselves as the leading so if
you see like our tagline for formal
James is the Northeast's leading digital
and techno Koopman agency I did that
ballsy like right from year one when I
had loads of other competitors bigger
than me but leading is leading like it
doesn't say you're the number one best
eye or not cuz no one else went out to
do that so that gave a perception
already are well they are the leading
and it came synonymous because the more
we kept appetising it and pushed now on
social media and LinkedIn then it just
became real and now it is real because
there's no one else that can touch us in
the Northeast so it's always about
practicing success before you really
successful and perception is reality so
you're not lying as such but you can
it's the way you word things and you get
people to see things yeah
because I think that's the thing is like
is that Lauren to know I'm in I get it
but yeah okay so honest like I was
always honest we look like we always
start or but we can deliver like yeah
can you deliver to that customer mmm do
the night do they know like and trust
you to be knowing you need to like be
bigger than you perceived so that's why
we leverage things like virtual
assistants at the time we pushed on a
lot of content on LinkedIn which is all
in organics we made a lot of noise
because all of the other agencies back
then didn't really understand marketing
which I know will come on to which is
very very important yeah have any clear
marketing strategy so we would build up
perception up and that
that Grund quite quickly for little cost
as well okay
so just on the 350 gram first year you
and younger brother at home I guess just
quickly before we sort of move into the
next couple years and sort of where how
you got to where today like in hindsight
now looking back what what what do you
what do you wish you did differently or
what advice would you give yourself
knowing what you know now do you think
number one highest slow fire fast I
hired two quick fire too slow for sure I
kept on at people like I was getting too
much of a chance to for sure
always remember cash is king like your
money in the bank not like invoices do
like actual money in the bank have a
clear client acquisition strategy our
system develops you've got constant
stream of inbound leads coming in and
wins because if you're not out there
meeting kinds of pitch and business then
the rest of you know if you do an admin
or operational it's not effective so I
was really key with my time like I
learned like to be really precious with
my time my time is speaking to clients
mmm because everything comes down to
systems like and it's won't like break
it down into little steps because to be
excellent it's something you have to
break everything down systemize it
understand what worked what didn't work
and once things really work that's when
you can really skill those areas but it
was yeah what was what was the what was
why you can say well she just over the
last four years but what's been just
talking about system processes what's
been the best or the handful of best
piece of technology or systems that
you've invested in would you say good
question we used to have a lot of tech a
lot more than what we did now because as
entrepreneur you shiny object syndrome
so you pull that on pull down before you
know I've got like 15 16 tools is to
manage the tools then I hire more
virtual assistants to hire the virtual
assistants that are managing the tools
and then
complexity bricks so Apple is a great
part of that with Steve Jobs like
everything was really simple so every
time you add another layer of complexity
like there's all sorts of problems that
can go wrong exactly
now I really simplify the business so
we'll have try and just use one tool for
one specific thing that works instead of
adding on every other tool well yeah
well like if you were to start
recruitment business tomorrow where but
what would be your like gold like
genomic a little technology starter pack
what would you assess it I would
probably obviously LinkedIn Makuta
although to a certain point because it's
expensive and they control the market
like we've got to be honest I cling to
my cooter without you there's no
chanting startup business with our fresh
yeah it's Lincoln McCray oh yeah Lincoln
makuta and you need some sort of email
find a mobile phone tool we've used
lusher in the past yeah you know anymore
but that could be good and one only
teaches like how to map the morgue and
I'm old-school spreadsheets but then I
would have data people to gather all the
dead of insert in one market and then I
would build an email automation outreach
strategy to engage with that market and
I would build out my dream 100 between
100 strategy and I would dream or dream
home 100 clients yeah and then eight
different touchpoints we do within our
business ok into that market
so I would do less tools and more
strategy and actually building proper
systems that don't break so an approach
technology where you need it but in
terms of hacks I mean there's LinkedIn
tools as well but a lot of those are
getting fun now you know and the
different one more email automation
tools you use we've tried reply dot IO
we use and we'll try it at the minute
which is quite cool yes that's probably
the best one that I've tested on the
market so far and what what is it cool
sorry the plyo replied the ayah ok cool
but it's not just about the tool it's
how like how yeah yeah yeah OCN hi so
people think they're just gonna get jobs
in BAU yes like that's that's brought in
jobs and
I've been lucky where if centers a job
spent and said if you agree 15% in go
ahead but that's very very rare like you
need to learn have off-the-cuff
conversations and being able to bring it
from a reply into yeah Paul yeah with
your strategy and how you like why call
you're unfair advantage any market like
what is your unfair advantage in your
niche that don't you do differently to
everyone else you're unfair advantage
yeah I love that so like what we do is
like ours as digital marketing in Bob
Martin and so we can help clients with
friend attraction brand awareness social
media video content like what can you
done because we're the only agency in
the Northeast fully connected to every
tech person in the Northeast and the
know like and trust us we've got a dead
fund where we do deaf events like all of
these things are unfair advantages so
anyway the three years behind and no
chance a lot of that phrase unfair
advantage I think that's that's a great
way to put it I like that and look I
have I have to ask you because I'm sure
some people thinking and then we'll we
sort of go into the next couple years
when you're hiring people nor that but
like just could you mention it quite a
lot I'm people might be like people may
think this this is alien to them may not
think it's possible I've had my own
experience within my own business now
but VA is how easy was that like let's
just talk about for asset because
because I think the way the you talking
described about your business James and
probably a huge factor as to why and
you've been able to build the business
that you want is that like if you just
think about the way you describe in your
business it's definitely not the typical
way that you would build a recruitment
business do you not I mean so talk about
VA talking about email automation
talking about and marketing driving in
bounds all these types of things I think
I'd like to think that the sort of
future generation of recruitment
entrepreneurs will be building
businesses more the way that you have
all the way that you describing it right
so VA s and leveraging and resources
like virtual assistants is definitely
part of that and and I've done that
myself but I can just imagine people
thinking what is he
like that VA was young about like how
how the hell can I use that as a
recruited you get what I mean so just
quickly what's like just to talk a bit
about your experience or how important
VA is or how good of investment VA is
have been for you earlier on or still
now to this day light just quick than
that because I have a half the marshy
it's a good point because I think I'm
because it's easy for you to think there
are every one things this is how you
build a written business I should have
explained that at the start so you've
got the old traditional way of a
recruitment agency which is of the wall
street that I came from nothing wrong
with those agencies by the way that
because that takes a lot of energy to
amour P sales people everyday get them
on the phone yeah the eyes chase down
that lead try and get in there first
like it's it's it's [ __ ] tiresome and
I've got like my hat's off respect to
people that do because there's a lot of
agencies on there that make that work
that's quick and that's for them like I
said before it comes down to first
principles and when you start the
business well what type of life do you
want to live
yeah because you can get your starting
conditions right otherwise you [ __ ]
like you need to make sure that you
understand what you want out of an
agency I knew I didn't want that anymore
yeah I want to build an eye to the front
I could but I have not got the time and
energy to do that yeah I from where so I
call it the new year agency which is all
around like what I would call like a
small boutique agency that leverages
tools technology a niche within a niche
a clear kind acquisition system relying
on virtual assistants a great culture
self managing business and then you've
got like a lot of systems taking out the
human element you've got the recruitment
delivery but then you've also product as
a service so we product as our service
now so we only pitch for a retain
business in with recruitment and
marketing and all its exclusive in the
northeast like there's only two options
but we're gonna dig into that man yeah I
knew from the start if I wanted freedom
lifestyle and still the meat storing
conditions
eliminate all of these tasks haven't the
TVs to the system script and job boards
finding
building up markets managing the
outreach templates in campaigns like I
knew there's a better way so I've spent
a lot of time paid for courses learn
from people for three years to really
refine my virtual assistant sourcing
strategy in sourcing system okay got it
to a point where live ears would rate
the candidates book and the calls for
the recruiters which still happens today
and probably one third of our deals give
or take depending on which which person
would come initially from the outreach
form one of the days okay we'd be stuck
with that but then you could also add
different perks and different tools and
we stood that back and just kept it
basic because like I said the more
complexity or more layers gets too
complex so a virtual assistant is good
you can toast I do give advice and going
up work fiber but people get it wrong
because the thing it's just going to be
in order it's not yeah I think cuz that
allows gonna be my next fing gems like
just because I think a lot of people and
I was that I was one of these people
where it just took it just took me it
just took me to that sort of initial
overcome they're like how how difficult
I think it's gonna be or how much hassle
is going to be to just overcome that to
them and just speak to a couple of
people think about okay if I hire a VA
what I want them to do let's map out
that process what though I want help
with blah blah blah and what one should
actually just get over that sort of
paralyzation of god this will be really
difficult or it's just gonna be
challenging and then you just yeah think
about what I want help with and then you
just start having conversations with
people it's just way more easier than
you think but I think a lot of people
can think oh that's just way too much
hard work or then it's worth you know I
mean to even get started so I guess what
would be your clear done it for a while
when it's a big part of your business
like just you sort of go to advice to
get to make people help you but take
action on trying to make a VA part of
their recruitment business or or
whatever like what would be your go-to
advice on that like actually start the
process do they need to just want the
needless understand the fundamental so
they need ever follow
blueprint of someone else it's done it
ie me because easy way they do it in
three years shows come on you at the end
but I can help people build on virtual
assistant teams if they need to these
are the companies out there that do it
in general tip to hire BSO I know
there's a lot of what you call up yours
others like unsourced Indian teams yeah
all of our vias are from the Philippines
just because I speak fantastic English
like English is pretty much a first
language over there the very loyal and
but you've just got to set the
foundations right it's it's hard on a
podcast to say yeah yeah I know you mean
I don't know I just don't want everyone
so cuz I'm cuz I because I've been
through that process not that scale but
I've been in that process and I just
knowing people will think it's way more
difficult than it is do you not I mean
maybe so maybe a better question would
be and then we can move on would be what
was what what's the most pop like what's
the most common misconception of the A's
would you say no they just they're
probably not going to do as good a job
as me which is there that's number one
like the results aren't gonna be as good
as you doing it yourself but you need to
put a value on your time per hour yeah
time per oh it should be at least 1,500
pounds power so you can get someone to
do it for 5 pounds an hour and 60 70 %
in with a view to always improving yeah
but it is I'll be honest at the start
it's a lot of time income you because
you have to manage them and you're gonna
get the Strayed yeah it's a process that
allows gonna be myself fun upon on it
it's a process but as you said a year
two years free is however long it takes
its then when you're aiming
it's another unfair advantage isn't it
because I said to me so I knew I didn't
want 100 stuff in my office because I am
NOT a great manager I don't have a
desire to have a hundred employees I
want some employees cuz we have a great
culture and I love coming into my office
with people I really love being around
but for these tasks like I knew if I
wanted six holidays a year and to take
Monday's off whenever I want I could
have a virtual assistant team that's
easier to manage once I've built and
the process in this year then it's
cheaper more effective less overhead and
it's it's more flexible but it's it's
gonna be more kin free in the long term
but I suffered more pin at the start
yeah okay cool
I know see we can never do the like
virtual the VA like yeah okay caught so
going into year two then James what was
it was the plan then right I want this
to be I know you're talking about how
you wanted your business but like did
you envision obviously it been more than
just you and your younger brother like
what sort of what was then the sort of
mindset going into how can you then grow
this business from a six-figure business
to a seven-figure business what was the
sort of mindset or strategy as to how
you gonna go about that yeah because I
have told us this and I will talk around
the journey because I have went from
lifestyle to all of a sudden actually I
want to build a business and build to
sell and then it was like transitioning
back to something in-between where I'm
building I said and a business to sell
but it's unique it's the new year agency
it's not a traditional agency yeah if
one day I want to sell the business grid
if not it's gonna make me a hell of a
lot of money so I'm fine
but like second year was and we hired a
girl called Isabella it was a great girl
just had a little baby now so she's on
at the moment but it was just Austrian
office so that's when we got was
probably mid win year one anyway but we
had a serviced office four-person office
but with three people in further in
Isabella toon delivery in kind of its
and then I was still like winning X I
was working so much on how can we
product as our service how can we be
really different unfair advantage how
can we get more retain business and
exclusive business and really box a know
that probably the Tom I've talked about
the dream on under like our top 10 at 15
20 clients that we wanted in a northeast
we pretty much won them all by the end
of the I too because I set those
expectations and I put that on to the
universe that we wanted to work with
them and I didn't put as much importance
on it I didn't stress it and it all just
came and that's all around with
different flow of psychology in terms
mindset thought like second year was all
about like can we get close to the
million pound mark but all
so not not sacrificing our fundamentals
the systems because as it started
growing and scale and say ie that's all
brought in another three beers and have
another person like things break again
so then you need to rebuild and refine
it yes
so second guy was still enjoying
enjoying the agency enjoying the rewards
of up because remember came from when in
sixty some UK yeah to like I could easy
take on one in fifty first like yeah of
the NATO I start buying like a bigger
house so then we saw it in the house up
I got nice car went on nice holidays
with my girlfriend at the time like all
of those things I was enjoying the life
as well as the business but then I was
putting processes in place everything
that we did is systemize processes so
that was like from everything from
recording to document in in a big
document on business so I was always at
the start had mindset to build the
business to sell in a systemized way but
it was different to the traditional norm
yeah so second year was good like I
think we finished on I'm sure is 600 650
mmm-hmm I remember rightly which is
which was really good that I mean
there's only like 3 min employees
actually I did hire two that sucked
after two or three months of so I was
kept trying to attract with home working
so I had two people that will work from
home workers that didn't work so again
because of them I was trying to force
that model so I was trying to adapt it
to between I didn't want a full-on
office agency with loads of employees
there's really more work and laptop
lifestyle recruiters that was very hard
to adapt to as well so that's not - now
we've transitioned this is yeah for now
like into really good delivery
consultants still about a couple of 360s
but then it's all around having a PD
person and delivery yeah secondary like
was really good again enjoyed it and
then we're moving on the 30 I was behind
it was difficult yeah we're being honest
it didn't really enjoy it as much
because I brought on a lot of stress
myself because I differentiate it away
from all of my core beliefs and suddenly
think that oh well to grow like we need
a higher more
stuff and I think you get why where did
that come in you see it's easy god am i
right isn't it
yeah well obviously to keep growing it
you do need at some point mom Chloe
steer course
so much I can generate and my brother
but I think you get trapped in the fact
of all well others are doing like 10
million pound turnover because if you if
you speak to other recruitment honest
how many stuff you got yes it's the
first question isn't it spoken by futons
is it but that's nothing because now
then a transition back is like I'll make
a lot more profit than most other
recruitment agencies now because we've
got it to a point where it's a really
lean perfect it out model where it's
lean to a point where we don't need
overheads when we for the sake of it but
yeah I got through that cycle so I hired
a lot like I think I went through about
eight mistakes in terms of hires
so I spend a lot of time you think
hiring interviewing yeah boarding them
manage them then firing them and then
done we damaged because we try in
critical culture so we sort of finding
our feet with that so I think yeah three
was probably what was the learnings in
that Lynn Jones because I think a lot a
lot of people challenge a lot of people
don't leave that cycle all like that you
know I mean some people remain in that
cycle if that cycle is that a new eight
people a sort of core people are there
that sort of is solid and they've got
that assorted but and then they're the
sort of four or five eight more people
and so for that is just a constant cycle
and chaos of getting it wrong learning
onboarding then they leave blah blah
blah so just just quickly Matt cuz I
know people get money from him to gone
back to fundamentals and I had different
mentors again back then and I realized
like remove myself from the recruitment
world again and thinking from business
logically in first principles and
actually engineering what I wanted out
of the business yes like not following
what everyone else was doing because the
problem was like you get absorbed with
oh well we're home in this way and these
are our sales targets these are our KPIs
and this is how you need a manager and
this is how you pitch and and I moved
back into my listening to myself again
my studies and like I said we've this
engineer and everything they think well
I don't want that business I get out if
really do not like it and that's not
what I want to create so I started
reshaping and remodeling how that
business looked so I stopped stripped
all box of thinking what has worked
really well in the business so we went a
lot of exclusive and a lot of retained
we've really drilled down into the
nation and office because we tried we
still do a bit in the northwest
Manchester but we tried different
locations and trying to hard like was
pointless like we Haven one or two
recruiters to go and do another market
but that takes a lot of energy and
resource a lot a lot of people think
them like if it's a niche within the
niche that isn't enough though and there
isn't enough there than what like enough
there for what they want it to be you
know I mean so yeah you've got it was so
like how I mapped the market out is you
gonna have to have at least a dream on
honey can happen at least one of the
good clients that are growing on a trend
I would hire at least three or four off
your three job titles in a year for sure
yes that's one of the things I'd look at
how many candidates is about three to
five thousand on LinkedIn grid is there
a about a thousand companies yes great
so you've got a market there that should
do at least four or five or six hundred
K but then it comes back to profit so
like I was going back so we made less
money in year three than we did in the
era yeah on that too and I was like like
what the hell's going working harder my
Monday's off were gone and I had less
holidays I had less time to spend on
myself and so I wasn't in the right
headspace tell me what cleats then James
because like I think a lot of people
again perhaps a light where we started
this conversation right Wyatt right
starting conditions and these lots of
things like you're talking you're the
personal describing is the person that
you were talking about there ends up in
a business that ends up doing the
business that they don't like so like
like because a lot of people will be in
that position that you were describing
that you're in and think okay well this
is this is the business I have like how
can you step back out of that so I guess
like was there a moment where like no
this is enough and then like what do you
how did you then just make the decision
to step fact you know I mean was there a
particular moment that driving
these different masterminds have
attended I go to one in LA at the moment
and they're not recruiters that don't a
lot of them don't own and service
agencies but they were all pretty much
younger than me and they were making
between one five ten million pound yeah
it was a [ __ ] like why am I wasting my
time working a bit of reality check for
me I was like yeah elevate like I was
back again personal growth so like
really like deep diving into my analysis
of my brain what will get me from A to B
will not get me from C so the person I
became I did change and adapt and it got
to seven figures okay so but what's
gonna get me more to that is to be a
bigger mindset you need to change a lot
of the fundamentals so it's back to
always things like plan fun tomorrow
today your health like are you looking
after your health in terms of like
looking after yourself meditate and
gratitude like planning your perfect
week planning the business around like
what you want to do like I knew I was
going against my core belief like my
truth there's like you your agency and I
was like it was a wake-up call for me
was like gyms are why I'm coming into
work I was coming into work on the third
year ischium and I was like good floors
and the door was like and I was just
distracted I could see myself looking at
different things I'm like I'm not I'm
not enjoying it and but it was it was a
reflection of me in the mirror so you
need to have that reflection yourself to
analyze what business you created you've
created that monster so I was like well
I got myself in that let's get myself
back out of it and stripping it all back
and then it was less about revenue less
about headcount it was just all about
profit like can we be as profitable as
possible yeah and productizing the
service again working on that doing what
we did best
so was gone back to the fundamentals of
niche within a niche sticking to the
northeast market me still going out to
meet the right type of clients but being
picky about the retained increasing our
crisis because we were the best in the
market what we delivered and in
different value ads I worked on all of
that and that came from the mindset of
Nona I got us into that like sort of not
mess as it were but like I wasn't yeah
it was
yeah I love my agency now all of the
people that I've got because that was
another thing I was like you hired
different characters and then how you
mean I would never hire than me that was
in Nigel Frank because I was a dick yeah
like money but it would have been like
the culture wasn't right as well yeah
like going back to like a crew then I
start creating what I've done now as a
self managing culture self managing
company so everyone manages themselves
all they do is creating it under their
report and slack it to me I'll check it
off to get them understand and if
they're it's a business within a
business they've got their targets to
hit they've got their key tasks that you
need to do per day but I'm not down the
neck they get a lot of freedom and
autonomy but just don't take the person
and that's what it was like so given it
my staff like trust and respect yeah so
I guess you're talking about there but
what I just came to segue into them
James it was light what what were there
I know you've sort of broke it down but
like what just for people listening and
sort of you going on this journey with
us which I really appreciate you being
really honest is like what what were the
key things that you change them going
into year four that you put you now in a
position where join going back so you
just said they're building a self
managing culture which I really like the
sound sound of and really interesting
but what well I know you said you
stripped it back and that's of different
things but what were the sort of key
things that you change that really put
you in a position where you're now yeah
as you said happier enjoying it again
back to being in the business that you
want to be in and the business that
you're that you want to build rather
than what you've just been describing
yeah I would say like focusing on our
actual market so building a new products
week to adapt and give what the market
really wanted a lot around like I said
mindset so we all like raising my
average standard so I got in a comfort
zone because I was making good money and
I had most things I want it now so like
a good house the things so I think I saw
a little bit yeah a bit complacent yeah
it definitely a little bit and and then
frustrated because I hired people that
weren't right and not just yeah
and then I didn't really enjoy being in
the business as much and then I was
looking at different things I think it's
side-swept in terms of why I'm just
gonna build this business
get rid of it sell it for 510 million
now you thought of different transitions
you go through like building there's
seven figures then then like there's a
lot of bad advice you can get as well so
I was it's not listening to myself more
and really raise my standards or raise
my game in terms of what I do every day
not necessarily just in the business but
outside of work who ever listened to
what I surround myself with what I do
every day in terms of my actual like
standards because when you keep raising
your standards as a human as default you
will go to the lowest standard that you
will exert so like most people are at
this level but I vacuum reasoning to
here and then when I have a lazy day or
just a good average
I'm keep raising it so I could push
myself in other areas of life that
reflected in business so it was like
sometimes your business is a self
reflection of what's going on in your
personal life as well and what other
habits are you creating in your
surroundings so I think I just push
myself through that barrier if like
really working on my inner self a little
people don't leave people might be
thinking about now James and think well
how can work on yourself make you more
may may help you build more of a
successful recruitment business so I
just I I know we've spoken and like I
love the sort of amount you're talking
about mindset and these sorts of things
but just add a bit more context to that
James you know I mean because I think
something might be listening going okay
James I get it but how but how how can
that then read this book the power of
the subconscious mind by dr. Joseph
Murphy I'm a big believer in stuff like
that so mindset mindset it's like pass
the law of attraction stuff in physics
and we are energy so energy like that
you notice another way agencies like you
know when you're going to already got
all that pressure and yeah that's no
good because that's what dr. David
Hawkins talks around in a book power
versus force which is another book I
really and that's an absolute for
economic different levels of
consciousness so I've just elevated my
levels of consciousness instead of being
everything buying you like force
things like I am instead of like force
like I'm using just power off like me a
truck and these things because I was
looking at if I'm going to operate at
this level you're going to be stressed
burn don't yes you might be rich but
most people are stressed looking for
external validation in terms of
different things are buying the hell
it's going to be at risk they're going
to be stuck in that cycle they're not
going to have a relationship after this
business though if you see a lot of
people getting forces etc and I wanted
it to be more effortless less stress
happy good foot inside myself we didn't
contributing and grown as a person like
all these things like come from your
subconscious mind because our brains
were wired from when we were 0 to 7
years old and all of our 95% that
beliefs we've got limited beliefs that
happened within that time you need to
rewire your brain so it's a lot around
like personal work on your cell via a
brain so another good book is psycho
cybernetics by maxwell schwartz that's
probably one of my key books that are
always recommended to people because a
lot of people are fighting through fear
like most people have felt that don't
start recruitment business it's just
fear gotta be happy and comfortable with
home comfort and unknown stuff em is an
entrepreneur in the game of life well
the more you elevate your levels of
consciousness they're more things that
you see in the more things you attract
yeah the less importance that you put on
things don't put pressure on it come
back for builders that are listening and
now don't put importance on a deal
if it happens it happens if it doesn't
it doesn't you set the expectation we
don't put importance on it because you
know the more importance that you pick
on closing the deal
the less likely that will happen it's
just not gonna happen so a lot of like
make you say you do working on yourself
or then translates into a better a
better version of James turn up to
business making better decisions and
that yeah that having an impact on the
environment you build the people that
you hire and yeah yeah because what you
think you become you've got to think
comes and people are geared for primal
fear just in the situation that we are
with the pandemic like people watching
the news and video
not like no like I haven't I've switched
off totally from any news like I never
watch the news anyway because it's all
negative well people are creating the
illness themselves by thinking this
because they're listening all of that
negative so switch off things like the
news like listen to the right people
surround yourself with the right type of
people as well like all of those things
is key like most people that are
successful it's like yes have strong
business fundamentals you got put in the
work you gotta put in the hustle correct
in the right way
can't just work without the strategy in
a plan that's that's that's incorrect
like you need to make sure you've got
the right plan you build in the right
thing and it feels right for you because
if it feels congruent with your true
inner self like you will find a way for
it to happen a lot of people are
building things that aren't right for
them and that wouldn't have been
business in the corn get out of it a lot
of people have got bigger businesses and
me more stuff and making more revenue
but the making less profit and a really
unhappy and they built this themselves
because it's a self reflection of
themselves in a mirror and it all comes
back to yourself
mmm not the business so look so just to
round that off then like how so
you going so you still win here for now
or in 2020 so no this is our midway
through our fifth year no because like
that just lets just run off I'd like
like then where did you finish as a
business year for then revenue net fee
income wise revenue I think were 1.2 1.3
million which is not the income because
we didn't do contract okay in more
profitable like in terms of like the
profit that we've made and this year
we're going to be on target to do 1.8
million but that's including contract
like we've got one contract Makuta put
again I think I'm gonna probably be like
1.4 1.5 which I'm happy with because if
we can do over half a million pounds
profit like I've got like that's took a
long time to get there by the way like
it just ting that level I'll be really
happy because I'm doing a lot with my
coaching program now as I told you like
I really believe in mentorship and
guidance so my true true inner passion
is coaching which I'm going
helped other people start and grow
six-figure recruitment agency and
uncover all things building a virtual
team I love it mouthing that's quite
what we doing and just a quick one then
let's segue into that and sort of bring
this to the end I guess just one thing
that I wanted to just get your thoughts
on I know you've touched on that but I
just wanted to make sure I asked your
force experience with it because I think
a lot of recruitment businesses maybe
even through this period of learning as
well but it's definitely been spoken a
lot more of over the last 12 months
longer in terms of product size ASIC
product ization of your services right
and so I guess like right now like so
your your products are retained and then
you've got the employer branding piece
as well
so climate got a full marketing solution
which I know I've got a really cool
product that's been we've been working
on Tunis downtime with my marketing
manager which is due to be released in
the next couple of weeks which is what I
would call a blend between doing the
actual recruitment for the client to
actually showing them the marketing tech
marketing in-house so we can build them
an in-house talent acquisition system
mixed with the recruitment fundamentals
because a lot of internal recruiters
like I know there's always a bottle but
like they don't know the brand piece the
marketing piece and everything else and
we've created like a training solution
for that as well so why is it important
for recruits to be thinking about
product ization of their services
well definitely because of an unfair
advantage right we've discussed yeah and
also like remember clients now like
after this are going to be very very
picky around do they really need an
agency what value you gonna bring to me
yes you're gonna send me a C label
there's going to be tons of people
offering it a 10% 12% cuz they'll be
scraping around deeper to survive or
people there's gonna be a lot of more I
think recruitment stops where people
have been furloughed
which I get a lot of applications I've
been let going out I've been thinking
about starting my cellphone we're
definitely there's a lot of recruiters
that wouldn't even thought about
starting their own agency which the
owner under more informed the podcasts
are yourself and I mean
there's more information so it's a lot
easier to start a recruitment business
than ever before so you really do need
like productize in a way where you are
offering something different niche
within a niche like not general so like
for instance like if it's within a
certain sector job Thailand certain in
certain type of companies that you
provide for whether it's SMEs a
mid-level market yeah I think you have
to have that's going to be a
differentiator we've you've got to work
like I've invested a lot myself like in
in different courses and learning what
other people are doing in America and
different places like trying to and then
try and get those thoughts into your own
signature service as its signature
service you can't just copy someone
else's or like make it overnight like
it's work and this is the problem that
most recruiters only know recruitment so
I'm always said I'm a business person
business personal go first end it's just
a skill that I've got like mmm not the
other way around most the crudeness over
coughing I think that's the correct
mindset like that it should be the
mindset do not I mean because yeah
totally okay so and you mentioned it
there in terms of your sort of ruin a
passion help them recruit to start their
own business what let's just talk about
that for a set before we finish lot
recruit is listen to this podcast a lot
of business owners listen to this
podcast but with you in the
conversations that you have what what
are the sort of common things that you
hear or common challenges that you hear
from people that I do have that fear of
starting our own business that you talk
to them about when overcoming it like
what just the common challenges that you
hear a lot of the time yeah I think just
not knowing how so like how am I gonna
win clients because again in the used to
the traditional way like still I use in
a lot of the systems and the tools so
like knowing how to build a solid client
acquisition system is one of the key
things that we do so you've got constant
clients coming to your inbound and
there's a win techniques of how you deal
with those clients and how you pitch for
your services and win their client so
that nut needs mapped out for them is
number
on how you actually map on the market
and know what needs to pick mmm having a
clear platform template and system to do
that and then a lot of things holding
people back like they think little
things like even things that makes a
website finance how do I get paid all of
those little things I'm like well you
don't you worry about that yeah just win
any first kinds it's a step by step you
get ahead it's like building each block
as its required but a lot of people like
again holding people back is the secure
security fear comes back to my
insulation yeah walking around like for
you to change to be a recruiter to a
business owner is not just setting up a
limited company on companies house
anyone can do that creating a website
anyone could do that
it's you need to change your mindset
we're not going to prepare to put in the
work every evening I'm reading for
two-three hours every single day still
and and that's been the last five five
years plus attending must have suspend
about over two hundred thousand pounds
in terms of courses mentors like I'm
prepared to keep elevating my levels I
feel more thing on that is like like
it's good that's good that's good I just
just because I love the way you know how
much I love this James and we've
connected on this and I think it's so
important to communicate the work and
then yourself doesn't mean that meeting
that means that you can have get even
more out of your criminal career and
it's definitely what we should be
talking about not many people do but I
think what I just wanted to make clear
in my opinion and hopefully agree or you
might disagree is that that's got what
you just said there has got to be
capable of action like I do you know I
mean I've been with these things I've
done actually on my youtube channel
familiar because yeah because like I've
been to the Tony Robbins unleash the
power then I've read obviously quite a
few the bit so you mentioned and I think
that's the thing that I think people can
get caught up in and also the and also
why when you said is my some angry
spending this money and then all that
there's that sort of sometimes stigma
that it's like ash bollocks
like just because you do there are
people they don't know what you don't
know like yeah like this you do not know
like what you're gonna go through to get
to a million
million pounds plus make this things
that you that's why you need mentors you
need someone to follow or you need to
work on yourself to understand
understand how do you have to take
action that's the thing I think a lot of
people can get caught in that self
development cycle of wrong I'm gonna
peds go in this next course next course
and they're always waiting for that next
course to be like the golden bullet like
whatever but that's what I just wanted
to add to that James I love the way that
you're talking about this you know ID
okay well look
before we finish then James what what
are you what are you most excited about
after this difficult period that we're
all going through what you're most
excited to do what you're most excited
to be see I don't know what you're most
excited about when we start coming back
out of this yeah to be honest like I
might be different than other people but
I've looked this time to work on myself
less distractions I've got a home office
here go for walks every day I mean is
Seneca say is like one of the great
philosophers like everyone moons about
not having much time on this planet but
like when you actually break it down and
at the time people waste per day like
everyone's got enough time on this earth
to make an impact but people just waste
it and then before they know what
they're on a death and regret I should
have done this you know and I know for a
fine [ __ ] there's gonna be a lot of
people are gonna regret when this all
gets lifted and the back to work like oh
I wish I used that time that we're on
Netflix to work on myself or should have
done this [ __ ] on that so many people
are going to regret this time that
they've got now when they can actually
really self reflect like Journal
I got journal my thoughts every day all
of these things so I enjoyed this time
more than like going back into the work
but I'm excited because this is sort of
a recession but there's never been a
time when government's like pump in
funding in like bounced back loans like
everyone get 50k just to get into the
business straightaway 10,000 pound grunt
like all of these cheap money like
there's so much opportunity is gonna be
trickled down 3 and 30 billion pound
plus from just the UK economy like the
money is gonna be there somewhere it's
just learning to adapt there's the
famous Charles Darwin says it's in
nature on business
it's not the strongest of species that
survive would you see that an agency's
it's not the biggest of agencies that
going to survive nor the most
intelligent but ones baller most
adaptable to change
you need adapt what worked back
traditionally and recoupment will not
necessarily work in the future and
that's what I truly believe like it's
going to be less I think they'll get a
bit of a lot of internal recruiters
because companies will not be hiring
tens and 20s anymore
they're going to behave freelance so
they're going to be a little bit more
clever so they might use recruitment
agencies but it will be down to cost or
what's in it for them value so that's
why any product as a service I'm really
excited about how this next journey does
because in chaos becomes new order so
it's a level playing field again and I'm
ready like it's exciting any
entrepreneur should be excited in this
times because there's the most
millionaires billionaires and biggest
companies were built in recessions mm-hm
I feel sorry for the people that have
been unfortunate where they've had high
overheads and they just haven't been
able to survive this like I'm sure
they'll come back and bounce back
stronger which I know we didn't touch on
a day but cash is king like building a
financial war chest I was so lucky in
our last probably eight months really
where we want some big within us with
some big big clients that really
tidiness all about where we've had a big
crush yeah like and the big and that was
probably the biggest thing for me in the
last year was my goal was create a
million pound war chest just in my bunk
like making sure we've got that cash so
we could go 12 18 months pin our
overheads without going under and that
was the key thing I probably couldn't
knock on a pattern in year two or three
but like having that was is excitement
yeah I'm just exciting to see what it
brings obviously I've got my program
that I've developed over the last
probably the 18 months it's been in the
Megane in terms of what we've created
but basically we've created a 90-day we
could accelerate a program to help
people either either start at their own
agency or already got the mone agency
and they want to grow to six figures
plus and beyond by building a solid
client acquisition system which is why
Ronald James a virtual assistant system
and being able to build automate and
systemize your business and scaling up
to six-figure profits well
call like a New Age client attraction
system so that's what I'm working on
just because it's my passion
no this class I love it and look final
question and ask it to everyone so you
can answer this with a phrase a word I
said and that's what whatever comes to
mind and if you could communicate to
every single recruit out there they'd
listen recruit an entrepreneur a
business owner they'd taken or advice
that implements it tomorrow what would
James say to the people as my mentor Don
Pena says just [ __ ] do it
getting rid of self don't limited
beliefs force through forceful fear
there will be friends family telling you
no you stupid there'll be voices in your
head saying don't take the risk whatever
like you've just got to go through
adversity you've got a four screw turns
it's been actually pleasure man
thank you